is six feet under the ground still
crying about Disney characters we don't
give a f he really think we care about
Disney being gay talk something about
women being a
tell me which women you don't that's how
you'll be my president tell a woman to
her face you're not getting this man
that's it that's how you become
president bro DeSantis is dead it's not
even close and I don't think there's
anybody what is it the Healy or whatever
the girl is who Nikki Haley no Nikki
Haley oh yeah he's not even in a [__]
black Park whack how is the Santa's
gonna compete with that the poor guy
who's probably way more qualified in
many political ways Etc and by all means
a smart dude he's a veteran he's going
to be a shell of himself the second he's
across from Trump and Trump just starts
[__] Landing hey man he needs a
writer